if x and y are integers seven is less
than y is less than 16 and x / y is
equal to 2/5 how many possible values
are there for x so x and y have to be
integers and Y is greater than 7 in less
than 16
so let's before we even think about this
constraint right over here and this
constraint if we just had if we just had
this constraint right over here what are
the possible values for Y but Y is an
integer greater than 7 so let's see it
would be 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 and it
can't be equal to 16 so we'll stop right
over here so just with that constraint
here our candidate wise
now they're saying x over Y is equal to
2/5 or another let me just rewrite that
so they're saying X over Y is equal to
2/5 or if you multiply both sides by Y
you get X is equal to 2 over 5y
now if X is equal to 2/5 Y so over here
you had if you would have 8 times 2/5 so
let me write this down so these are our
possible wise wise and then our possible
X is 8 times 2/5 now is this thing right
over here going to be an integer
remember X&Y need to be integers
well no 8 isn't divisible by 5 8 times 2
is 16 16 isn't divisible by 5 and so
this is not going to be an integer is 9
times 2/5 is that going to be an integer
no 9 isn't divisible by 5 I think you
start to see a pattern here
10 times 2/5 is that going to be an
integer
sure 10 is divisible by 5 10 divided by
5 is 2 10 divided by 10 divided by 5 is
2 times 2 this is equal to 4 so this is
a possible value for X and frankly this
is a possible value this is a possible
value for Y if we have to assume that
they both have to be integers and so we
don't have to test all of these we just
say look which of these are also
divisible by 5 well 10 is divisible by 5
and 15 is divisible by 5 none of these
other ones are divisible by
five so if Y is 15 we don't have to know
what the value is but we could say X is
going to be 15 times 2/5 which is 15
divided by 5 is 3 times 2 which is 6 so
there are 2 possible values there are 2
possible values for x